Okay, so in the context of of
guidelines and planning, and
maybe overp lanning in a business,
there's a real danger for startups.
I think, or at least it's been my
experience that people who are not maybe
directly involved in the process
of creating the thing that's
at the core of the business.
Maybe in like a software company,
it's the engineers.
Or a marketing company,
it's the ads, or what have you.
The people who are making the decisions,
if they're too disconnected from
the actual acts of the company, there is
a real problem where they could create
plans that are just disconnected from
the actual realities of the business.
I mean, I can't provide off the top of
my head any direct examples because I'm
just forgetting all of them right now.
But I've seen companies fail
all the time for misdirection.
Bad planning, not understanding
what business you're actually in.
So, especially in startups where you
are effectively building a business
that has no roadmap, you cannot
build a roadmap in advance of that.
You can only reflect on the things
that others have done before.
And usually you're
going to get that wrong.
The whole purpose of
a startup is to carve a new
path in an area where
there are no paths.
And trying to calculate in advance
too far where you're trying to go or
what you're trying to do or how you're
going to get there can actually lead you
way off base from where
you're trying to go.